one of the great things about comic-con
is we get to sit down with some of the
people that are a blast for the past but
remember everything old is new again and
that's why we are sitting with the og
cast of Cobra Kai Ralph Macchio Williams
Ibaka and Martin Colvin first of all how
is Comic Con have you had a chance to
kind of digest it yeah we slept behind
that light
I was wondering whose blanket that was
uh what does it mean that your series
Cobra Kai is set now for a third season
and it really is just killing it online
well it's good it's a testament to the
writing it's testament to to the fans
out there they're there to come into the
party and telling their friends and it's
just built up and getting the chance to
be back with these youngsters again
pretty pretty amazing it was the kind of
cool response when you guys the first
season people freaked out a little bit
did they well they freaked out I think
they freaked out was I surprised it
could have gone either way I think
everybody we stepped into this very
cautiously very carefully and I think
the audience was skeptical at first but
won them over and word and that's why
we're here again season three yeah have
you seen a script yet for season three
yes would you like to know everything
I wouldn't know every tell you
everything I turn into a woman how much
fun do you have enogh doing this show Oh
working with these two characters it's a
lot of fun I mean the highlights are
really doing scenes with them for me
because the show's over it it's such a
gas to you know to do the words and
bring the characters back but we have
scenes together it's the best I just
enjoy that more than anything else
35 years ago now
Karate Kid game Wow can you look back
and it's still this phenomenon what do
you remember about shooting the movie
I'm getting my butt kicked no I remember
I do remember that and it's still
happening today
yeah no I think you know there was there
was something at Billy or scissors that
project was kissed in some way and we
feel the same way about Cobra Kai that's
just you know we're catching lightning
in the bottle twice
and but the Karate Kid making that film
and the casting the the direction from
John avildsen the script Robert came
into my home and just the whole
production had something special going
forward whether we sitting here having
this conversation that wasn't the case
but there's gonna be an internet thing
called YouTube that's why I'm playing
come on yes I saw this you saw it in
advance you knew how about the the new
audience that you brought into it who
now you know they're like all of those
guys they weren't a movie yeah and
you're like yeah there was a movie
called Karate Kid once a funny yeah well
we got a lot of dads have kids you know
and that said they were the kids of
yesterday they're the fathers of today
raising their kids and they're showing
their children crying kid
yeah Cobra Kai is taking off where that
left off this much time later and the
stories for the young characters on the
show and the young cast on this show or
so so rich and complex and it really
adds to you know is fathers and sons and
and mothers and daughters I mean anyone
could watch the show and and some people
Billy and I have discussed this some of
the young audience members backed
themselves into the Karate Kid universe
they'll see the show and then I'll watch
the movie with their parents or whatever
and it it builds from there so it's a
you know the riches come from that are
three creative heads that made this all
happen yeah they just know how to write
to a young audience they hone great
takes yeah it was good guys and bad guys
you know back in the movies yeah we were
the bad guys it was a good guy you bend
it but the bottom line was now all these
young characters are all great all the
teenage characters are great so that and
the writers creating it that way so
everybody everybody identifies with it
much more because you can't go why had
some black hats anymore audiences are
too sophisticated yes kids are too
sophisticated yeah you know it's funny
you talk about that
take you back to 84 we were on the set
of course and would you listen to this
[Music]
Wow pretty good those are prophetic
moment can I say that I'm gonna need to
use that in the future like I actually
occasionally having pearls that I
actually know what I'm talking about or
got very lucky or read the script
perfectly can we bring in the young
folks come on bring about I think we
have release that was actually last week
I want to bring in Xolo Mary and Tanner
we're gonna bring them in I have to ask
what did you know about Karate Kid
before you join Cobra Kai I'll take the
fall for this one I was I had seen the
movie I was super young when I first saw
it and you know even going out for Cobra
Kai I was very I knew little to none
about what Cobra Kai was until I showed
my audition to my mom and she was like
are you kidding me you don't know what
this is and it was like you this is a
big audition you know so so uh that's
that's my eyes by saying that's my two
cents about them but I mean now we've
all watched the movie now are you
watching yes I understand that you're
talking about something that's iconic
to some of us here don't mess around
with our traveling the point of like
actually like auditioning for it I
didn't know anything but like at that
point I wasn't gonna watch it in between
the audition in the callback or between
the callback and the producer especially
at that point is just gonna make me way
more nervous so I told everyone just
don't talk to me about it don't freak me
out I know it's now that it's a big deal
I didn't realize before but now don't
freak me out about it and I just tried
to get through the audition process and
then once I had booked it then I sat
down I finished all the movies yeah
they're they're fantastic by the way
don't forget Dan you got the girl around
the world there's one movie don't cheat
don't cheat us don't you know sound of
all and all the great moments one - guys
the action how
fun is it filming the action doing the
action out or does it get kind of hard
sometimes and who has gotten hurt he's a
bi gonna hurt everybody I blocked a kick
incorrectly and ended up in physical
therapy so I I've learned my lesson
balance no but actually no I I think the
physical aspect has been the coolest
aspect of this whole thing like it's
been so cool it was like amazing to walk
into this incredibly established
franchise and and be a part of that and
gets even just like have a fraction of
that for myself was so cool and then to
get to add on like the martial arts
aspect has been so cool and so like
challenging yeah yes well it's extremely
fun I mean this is we get the
opportunity to come in and actually have
fun and do as many stunts as we possibly
can we have great staff coordinators cuz
they train us really well all of us and
they try and get us in there as much as
possible so we can do just about every
stunt any sort of safety like they're
careful about our safety and making sure
that everyone is safe and protected and
taken care of and other than that they
want us to be able to do as much as we
possibly can and we all I think
challenge ourselves to do that how do
you think you guys found the perfect mix
between the old school in the new school
that it's such a success on a new
platform that's out there I think you
know obviously coming into the project a
lot of people come for you know Ralph
and Billy and Marty and they that's why
they came that's why we came and then
you watch the show and you realize that
there's so many other nuances and and I
think that's what keeps them you know
and getting to speak with you know I
have this like it's like great invite
everybody to the party then you get
there and there's so really awesome
but you know I I feel most of my stuff
with with billion and Marty and I guess
just learning a lot about what it was
like filming the original and saying yo
when you film this what were you feeling
because it helps you know because we're
trying to create a show that has the
same feeling but isn't formulaic you
know isn't the same step-by-step so so
getting to learn a lot from Ralph and
Billy and Marty it goes so far no well
you made the Karate Kid real quick we
weren't conscious of what we were making
at all and the rezident it became this
and it's and it's awesome that they
didn't see the movie before they stepped
in the audition cuz if I knew Jerry
white Rob was when I audition for karate
kid' I might have shut down too right
you know I knew John Allison was but he
was so nice but I'm saying is that kind
of going in just with your heart and
just put your heart in it doing the
characters you know it's written in a
way that it's gonna work if you just do
that
so to be conscious of what this is and
how big and important it's like none of
that it's just put your hearts into I
think that's what's resonating is the
kind of this it's a human thing it's
human story just as a frame of cry kid
and the three creators of the show Jon
Josh and Hayden who really keen truck
the child for them it is the ability to
have something being nostalgic yet
currently relevant right is really the
marriage that they they and they now and
then tone respect in homage to the
original but not but fine threading the
needle for what is you know is engaging
versus what's apparent and they think
all out of the box they think so far out
of the box they you know this is their
Star Wars so that it's really wonderful
to work for these guys because they know
more about your they know way more about
they know more about our characters when
we first met them we did and we're about
us personal that's the creepy boys
arrested beautiful the way you guys
described it but I think Xolo said they
come for him as long as they're coming
hey real quick did you keep the car from
the movie I did in support in season two
okay and they gave it but you know TLC
and it sits down ready for season three
right now so it's awesome it is the car
that we used in we shot in 1983 for the
release in 84 and it's the same you know
because it is comic-con we have lots of
surprises very but we have a little
surprise for you somebody who wanted to
stop by and say hello
[Laughter]
that's right Randle always pretty good
huh good if you think you were surprised
when this guy walked in you should have
seen what happened when we walk them
over on the convention by the way season
three of Cobra Kai coming up make sure
you check it out is a fantastic show
this is a fantastic cast and you know
what I love that the old guys don't get
any older they look better right thank
you guys for joining
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]